à rennes le centre commercial alma
troisième par sa fréquentation au niveau
national vient de faire peau neuve
à la veille de son 20e anniversaire
désormais donc une tour vitrée de neuf
étages qui a d'ailleurs été inauguré
hier par les personnalités de la région
rennaise surplombe la ville et la
campagne c'est donc le témoignage de
l'évolution de notre environnement ce
qui a suscité à loïc matthieu quelques
réflexions
demain c'est laurent se plaisent à
répéter les personnalités qui veulent
être responsable de tous les amis alors
pourquoi continuer à copier le géant
américain
mais soyons clairs le sens très en 71
fut une réussite économique et
commerciale aujourd'hui il est à la
mesure de notre société c'est la tour
alma citic dix neuf ans plus tard marque
l'achèvement de l'ensemble
c'est aussi la fin d'une certaine forme
de commerce incontournable évolution
diront les sociologues du commerce
le consommateur n'est pas seulement un
pigeon il faut le barde et de décors
appropriés
90 c'est la fin de la droguerie mercerie
du bonjour man babouins vous enfants
vont-ils bien user les sardines saleh
dans les tonneaux le client doit choisir
tout seul guide est conseillé par des
bandes aux diplômés incontournable
évolution la buvette du chemin de fer
est encore à la vapeur alors que nous
sommes déjà à l'heure du tgv mais la
buvette ne se forçait jamais dans
l'ambiance c'est casse croûte et ses
roses et l'e-mail sur fond de cheminée
opatija faisait le décor un bon
américain aurait sûrement exporter nos
bistrots et nos galettes saucisses mais
sans y prendre garde
le breton de rock se prend le big mac du
cousin donald en pleine poire et ça
marche
incontournable évolution mais surtout à
droite et les guidages de la
consommation et 6 ans 71 suffisait de
faire fonctionner la l'américaine pour
attirer le client
aujourd'hui il faut se creuser les
méninges
pour faire joli et lui rendre un peu de
sa chaleur perdue au consommateur
incontournable évolution pour survivre
les centres villes ont inventé les rues
piétonnes où l'on ad'abord piétiner sans
conviction avant de les adopter sans
concession pour les autres ceux des
banlieues ceux des bouleaux la bad au
dos ici il fallait inventer ça c'est
fait et depuis 20 ans les centres
commerciaux évolué dans le bon sens
commercial celui ci dans
l'incontournable évolution est plutôt
réussi sachez quand même que c'est nous
qui sommes indiscutablement responsables
de notre évolution que le grand marché
de la consommation n'a pas de
sensiblerie nostalgique et que nos
enfants sont depuis longtemps
alma city tant pis j'aime la buvette des
cheminots d'épicerie de la mer mariottat
la galette saucisse est l'heureuse élue
mais purée de nostalgie